La Búsqueda del submarino en el océano
es como Buscar en el espacio a pesar de
que Canadá y Estados Unidos desplegaron
barcos y aviones los labores Siguen sin
dar frutos Y es que los esfuerzos por
encontrar el sumergible desaparecido
mientras realizaba una incursión a los
restos del Titanic el pasado 18 de junio
son difíciles y se complican debido al
entorno desconocido que representa el
fondo Marino
los restos del Titanic están a 4000
metros de profundidad está oscuro y hace
un frío glacial no puedes ver tu mano
delante de tu cara la única manera de
saber dónde estás Es con un sonar ni
siquiera el radar funciona no pueden
tener una línea que lo ate hasta el
fondo porque sería demasiado pesado y
demasiada resistencia Así que es un poco
como la luna es como ser un astronauta
yendo al espacio
el submarino desapareció con cinco
personas a bordo sta clutch fundador de
Ocean Gates empresa propietaria de la
naveta y suleman the Wood de
nacionalidad británica pero miembros de
una de las familias más ricas de
Pakistán James jarding multimillonario
británico y apasionado por los viajes al
fondo marino y Jean pauld capitán de la
expedición con décadas de experiencia
navegando por los restos del Titanic
otros pasajeros que ya han hecho el
viaje explican que desaparecer en medio
del océano es un riesgo que asumir
al entrar tú sabes lo que estás haciendo
ellos sabían que esto podía pasar podía
haberme pasado a mí cuando lo hice allí
nadie entra sorprendido en eso
con el reloj en contra los equipos de
rescate Siguen con los esfuerzos para
encontrar el submarino mientras se agota
el oxígeno disponible a bordo